uh okay
good thanks thanks a lot for the
reminder and i'm going to go into full
screen too
so all right um so welcome good evening
everyone my name is ola i'm one of the
volunteers of the
pi data cambridge meetup and this is our
33rd
meetup for july 2021
and um quick introduction um
and and uh overview of the agenda we
have two talks
um so the first one is by tariq on the
eu's proposed regulations on ai
uh an overview and the second one is
by nishad an introduction to nurbs with
an
aerodynamics example nurbs has set the
right pronunciation i
i hope so um yeah i think so i mean it's
an acronym you're not really supposed to
uh have a have an official pronunciation
i'm sure but
um right so so very quickly a few words
about
us the pi data cambridge chapter um
so um we are part of
the outreach program of num focus which
is a u.s based
non-profit that is dedicated to the
promotion
of open source software and in
particular uh
open source software with a focus on on
data science and
analytics so we are part of the outreach
program we were inaugurated in november
2018 since then we've been running
meet ups nearly every month uh in person
in cambridge until the pandemic and and
virtual since then
and every last wednesday of the month
as of you know like as in today
and um there are four people
um organizing this this meetup together
uh federico who unfortunately cannot
make it today because she's on vacation
euris leandro and ola and
we are all volunteers so so we we have
daytime jobs but we are doing
this on the side and uh
looking at this list i i am reminded at
this list of names i'm reminded that
this is the last uh meet up for eures
where he is going to be in the uk at
least so so he's moving to
south korea um for a new job in uh
soon so um he is going to be
most likely less involved with the meet
up afterwards just because of the
geographical distance so thanks a lot to
eures for
his his work and and and dedication
and and input to the meetup um
so so a quick um quick word about num
focus
as i said num focus is um as a
non-profit
that promotes open source software um
a lot of the open source projects that
you are
familiar with um are supported by num
focus in various ways so sometimes
there's
sort of uh there's direct direct funding
going to
the developers of of these projects
sometimes uh they're sort of more
indirect support in in terms of
coaching um going on um
as the name suggests uh in in pi data a
lot of these um
projects are in the python space but
recently nam focus has also branched out
into
into other languages and and software
ecosystems so there's julia
on the list for instance and i think um
stan was at some point supported as well
yes and stun is also still on the list
so so it's it's a
with a focus on python but not only
python
and um as i said we are not
this is here this is all run by
volunteers
um so we're not doing this for the money
but um
and your num focus is also non-profit
institution but
if you um if you are so inclined
consider donating to nam focus there's a
link at the
bottom of the page and any donation that
you give will directly go
to the support of open source software
um
since we are part of uh the num focus
outreach program we are also bound by
their code of conduct
uh so here just very briefly a summer uh
summary of this code of conduct it's
quite simple be professional
um you know don't know we cannot
tolerate any insults or put down
of other people and any sort of
harassment
it should be common sense of course um
if you think something happened at the
meetup which
sort of violates this which violated the
the code of conduct
you can um you have a code of conduct
response team that you can reach out to
so first of all you can speak to all of
us the organizers
um but you can also we have also like uh
you have also an external person leonie
mc
who is also affiliated with this num
focus and you can also reach out to her
if you prefer
to discuss your concerns with an outside
person to someone who's not involved
directly with the meetup
we are also supported by several
organizations in uh cambridge based in
cambridge and
outside so these are arm fetchy i
num focus as already mentioned at the
raspberry pi foundation
um so so all these organizations support
us
or in various ways for instance by
paying for our
zoom accounts for for the meetup dot com
fees and so on and so forth and and
when at the time when we were meeting in
person uh
i'm also used to generously support us
with
pizza every month month this was great
so
um you know keep this keep these
organizations in mind
um and um and uh even you're
i don't know looking for a job or or
something like that
and it's just sort of like a couple of
news from these sponsors so
fascii is a machine learning um
startup based in in cambridge they are
heavily involved in
um in uh agent technology and and
have a couple of products around
distributed
ledgers inspired by by blockchain so
very
interesting technology you see a couple
of their announcements and
links to where you find further
information on this page
i should also mention that fetch ai is
hiring
in various areas around uh software
development machine learning
and so on and so forth so if you think
this sounds cool then please have a look
at their website
um then there's arm arm is also a
company uh headquartered here in
cambridge
in the the semi conductor and chip
design business
um they have also regularly
uh job openings around data and software
engineering
and python so if
you're interested in that you can either
go to the webpage directly or you can
uh speak to the volunteers federico and
leandro
leandro is also here on the call so you
can message him directly
um okay a couple of other
bits and pieces for information um i
forgot
to mention in the beginning that we are
recording this meetup so
um so my video my voice and this
will be recorded and of all other
speakers and we usually
um upload these videos with some delay
to the pi data youtube channel so i will
share
the link to the recording on the meetup
page
if you have any concerns about that then
please switch out
and let us know um and then
our usual announcement we are always
looking for speakers
um so if you you want to present
something
there's really a lot of flexibility it
doesn't have to be like a super polished
or very long target but if you have some
ideas
want to discuss do reach out we're also
always looking for sponsors so if you
have a company that want to
broadcast shop opportunities or you know
get in touch with data scientists
uh in in the cambridge area you know
come talk to us
and um with uh eures
um leaving we we're also looking for
um i would say one person to to join the
the
organizing team at some point in in the
future so
it's not maybe sort of like an immediate
commitment but we are hoping to
find someone at some point over the next
couple of months so if that interests
you as well you can reach us
below at the bottom of the page uh links
to
uh youtube channel our twitter account
and our email
um so and i can post that in the chat
as well okay so
without further hadoo i'm going to
stop sharing and i'm going to hand over
to the first
speaker with tariq ashit who are going
to speak to us about
ai regulations as proposed by the eu
fantastic thank you very much um it's
great to be here um
just to kind of very quickly introduce
myself i've spent about 20-25 years
working in
technology small companies big companies
about a decade in central government so
i've seen the impact of
data and algorithms on individuals and
communities
i'm currently focused on helping
organizations understand the risks
around the use of data and algorithms
similar to how
some people do the same for information
security
um i'll start showing my screen now and
hopefully that will work
can everyone see a big blue slide
yeah i can see it fantastic so what i
want to do today is just to
give an overview of uh what has been
happening
um at the eu level in terms of
regulating
the use of data automation and quotes
ai it's important to say that
these are proposals for regulation so
they're not set in stone
and some elements are likely to change
in the next year or two
um when i say an overview in the next 10
15 minutes we can't go into a lot of
detail
but i want to give you a feel for where
we have come from
some of the other standards and
regulations
that have informed this so you can
understand the kind of historic journey
we are on um and i know many people here
are
very technical and you know data
scientists and analysts
but it's always useful to understand the
wider context in which we work
the regulatory context so
very very simplified um time frame
gdpr was very significant for many of us
and it landed in 2016 it was a few years
in development
and its focus was on data protection
and privacy which at the time and for
the preceding sort of decade
that was the main concern for society at
that stage
um the state of the art the availability
of you know
advanced algorithms um you know the use
of data
uh it wasn't uh as prevalent in
in in industry and therefore the
questions around
is this safe to do is this fair use of
data is this a safe use of algorithms
it wasn't such a big concern but that
concern has been growing
and naturally now that has resulted in
both consultations around what
registration
regulations should look like and now a
draft proposal
i've also put in here 2019 the ethics
guidelines
that the eu produced which are not
regulation
but they set out a conceptual framework
for thinking about what is important
what isn't what are we trying to
preserve
what are the fundamental principles um
and it was actually
very influential it um it it was
copied and pasted or or it inspired many
governments around the world
in terms of their own publications
on how to think about safe fair and
ethical use of data and algorithms
and the private sector also took up um
some of that framework as well
so i put it here because it's um very
influential on these
regulations and also very influential in
how
many organizations think about it it's a
very short document i think it's 37
pages long
very easy to read plain english i
recommend it um
there's a lot of stuff that official
organizations put out that's
unreadable including in the uk so i
yeah i would i would definitely
recommend this one
there's some links there which you can
follow afterwards
um it's worth just very quickly sharing
a picture of some of the principles that
drive
the gdpr so you can understand the
history of where we've come from
gdpr was about minimizing the data that
you
collect and keep around accuracy and
accountability
securing that data so it's you know not
um
author it's not accessed by unauthorized
people
and so on so we are now very familiar
with these um principles
but they continue um and
they they are a foundation on which the
new regulations
build um as i've mentioned
the the last two three years has been
very active
in terms of many governments and many
you know official bodies like the turing
institute and
um uh the ada lovelace institute and so
on
doing lots of work around well what
should regulation look like
what are the principles through which we
analyze
the the quality of a system and here are
some some
some interesting ones that you should
look at and again if you only look at
one
look at the eu ethics guidelines
those of these guidelines set out seven
principles
which many of us agree are probably the
right ones
they talk about
governance and accountability they talk
about
technical robustness safety you know
what we might call accuracy and
performance
they talk about privacy data governance
which relates to the gdpr
but they ask us to think bigger as well
they ask us to think about
the wider societal impacts of our
automated decision making
so not just thinking about the
individual but actually what happens
do small scale effects scale up and
affect
societies or communities as a whole if
there's a green
aspect to this as well should you know
are we justified in
consuming so much energy and generating
language models
and so on transparency is really
important principle
because we can't trust something if we
don't understand how it works
if somebody tells us how something works
that's just them telling us
if they show us if they open it that is
a
key requirement for trust and trans
transparency the key requirement there
um
many people have talked about you know
making sure that our
algorithms aren't biased that they are
fair
and another key point which many of you
will be familiar with
is around human oversight um and human
agency so that
those who are the subjects of the
algorithms you know the the users or the
victims
um have an ability to come back and say
actually
this is wrong or i don't like this
automated decision
can we fix it um too often that is
scaled out in the sense that you know
organizations don't want to do that they
want to automate everything
and there is no working feedback
mechanism so these are the um
principles that were set out in the eu
ethics frameworks and they continue to
be important
into the regulation so the regulation
refers back to existing
frameworks
so i just want to say a few things about
um a little bit of
technical things about what the
regulation is so it's a regulation
not a directive so it's like the gdpr
so directives are objectives or goals
and
national governments will interpret them
and create their own national laws
whereas the regulations are actually
implemented directly they're not
interpreted
they are um they are the they become the
law
and it's the same law across the eu
across 27
member states um it also means that
the ultimate bodies that decides on
you know judicial cases or conformance
standards is the eu
not local governments so there is
reduces the risk of divergence
it has teeth like the gdpr um this one
um the current
proposal say you know there's various
classes of
uh failure which attract two to six
percent of global turnover
which is quite significant in other
cases it's that or minimum that you know
the
30 million so they mean this um it's not
uh toothless
regulation like the gdpr it's extra
territorial
what do i mean by this what i mean is
that
it applies when citizens of the eu
are affected so if you are a developer
or of
builder of a service that's based in the
u.s in south korea
in the uk if your users are in the eu
they have the pr they have the
protections of this
uh regulation um so that hasn't always
been the case
and what it means is that if you have
you know if you're a startup or a big
company in the uk developing services
you have to think about
your eu users and there's 450 million
people in the eu and the eu is a sixth
of the sixth of the world economy
so it's hard to ignore that and this
this like the gdpr creates a harmonizing
effect it means that
organizations in the u.s um in
asia in the uk now can't ignore
the eu regulations and what
often happens is it is they could they
either create special
versions of their products and services
that meet the eu standards
or they just say you know what it's just
easier to achieve the high standards set
by the eu
and and and and just be just do that um
so you've seen now with gdpr that
sometimes some services are different
when the consumer is in the eu or in the
us
and this is seen as you know positive
because it raises the bar
and it makes people ask well why am i
not receiving the high standards that
you are set
why should i put up with less
protections from from from
elsewhere and i'll come back to this
question of
does this stifle innovation a lot i'll
come back to that at the end
um the other thing to say is and and
many lessons learned from um
you know so 20 30 years of information
security
um it's important that there is
conceptual clarity
a clear philosophy underneath
regulations
because then you understand why you are
implementing controls implementing
processes and standards
if you don't know why you're doing it
and you're just told to do
a control or a mechanism or a technical
thing
you know it it you're it's not
satisfactory and you don't know whether
it's proportionate
and we spent too long in information
security
implementing controls and not really
understanding where they were necessary
and a prescription-led
approach means that people there's
unnecessary cost
it creates a tick boxing culture and
there's less flexibility
in actually thinking about what the
risks are so it's always important to
have that conceptual clarity i'm a big
fan of this
we learned a lot of lessons in
information security
in central government for example where
we moved away from prescription
towards principles and objectives and
allowed people to think about well
what are the different ways we can
achieve this
and in this case just like the gdpr it's
about human dignity
human rights uh which many of us agree
on um
they call them the axioms as it were
um the big feature which everyone is
talking about um is
that the the this proposed regulations
creates four classes of um
um of ai systems risk-based
uh risk to human rights and
a lot of the discussion
centers on these four categories so i'll
just kind of
explain them there's unacceptable risk
which means they're prohibited
and that includes things like social
scoring by governments
and we know that some governments do
this so that will be prohibited
uh exploiting vulnerabilities of
children use of submilling
techniques um to influence your behavior
which is an interesting challenge to
social media because that clearly uses
those techniques
so we'll see how that pans out um
the use of biometric identification um
in real time there's some confusion
there because
it is banned with some exceptions
and those exceptions depend on a
technical description
which i'll come back to so essentially
the message i'm giving you is
the proposals are out and people are
reading them and saying actually this is
not clear enough or there are areas here
which are subject to interpretation
but it's useful to understand that
there's a whole category of
prohibited use of
algorithms there's high risk which is
the most interesting
because there are areas that we want to
build solutions in
medical equipment financial services
government public services
self-driving cars auto pilots you know
education you know scoring your work uh
automating the process of recruitment
you know automated interviews or cv
scanning
these things are important and they
affect people's lives if they go wrong
or even small biases when scaled out can
affect entire communities
so those are high risk but also the most
interesting for us to
try and get right limited risk
the definition isn't totally clear but
there's still a requirement that
users are told that they are using an ai
so that they are clear
they can move away minimal risk you
might say well what is minimalist there
is no minimal risk
but they list some examples like video
game ai or spam filters
and i guess you could call that very low
risk
so the high-risk category attracts
um obligations uh standards for
certification things you have to do
and none of those things should surprise
you it's things that we've all been
talking about for years
now you know a proper risk assessment
um making sure you understand the
quality of your data sets
um the proposals actually set out the
you know
term the words would say they should be
high quality data sets but some of the
challenge that is well what do you mean
by equality
so there's some stuff to be worked out
but the direction is clear
they talk about logging but many of us
interpret that as auditability
reproducibility they talk about detailed
documentation
we interpret that as transparency what
what is it that you've built how does it
work
what has been the testing process you
know uh who did you test it on
clearly you know in making sure that
users understand um
you know their own rights and the fact
that they are using an automated system
and so on so these are the things that
you would expect and many organizations
now getting good at doing this but not
everyone
and it is a challenge for startups
because their costs are limited of
course
um as i said it's a proposal and at the
moment
you know the the community is very busy
in reading it and challenging it and
having talks about it
and here's some of the things i just
want to give you a flavor of some of the
things that people
don't like about the proposals so
although the proposals have tried to be
principles based they do veer into
describing things in technical terms
like what is an ai system what is
real-time use
of biometric identification does that
mean five minutes later is not real time
so some the risk there is that the
the technical definitions create
loopholes because they are not
uh sufficiently uh covering uh the
intended you know uh
implementations so there's some
challenges there
some uh civil rights uh groups i think
that
the there isn't enough um uh
talk about creating the
process of feedback or redress for
people to say i don't agree with this
so with gdpr you could say i want to
know what information you've got on me
i want to know how you used it and i
disagree with this
there isn't yet an equivalent in the in
the proposals
um there are exemptions um which could
be misused you know
uh detecting detection and
identification of criminals
that could be you know really widened to
all kinds of uses
there are some understandable uses
missing children and imminent terrorism
um the military as a blanket is exempt
from from this
and for some people this is concerning
you know automated weapons
that's a big area of concern for many
people
there's a practical bureaucratic
challenge as well because
the idea is that high-risk systems that
we've talked about
have to be certified and entered into a
catalog the database
and the ui database so some people are
thinking
this is this is crazy you can't do that
that's
too much paperwork too much of
bureaucracy but actually the challenge
back to that is
there is already equivalent systems for
you know electrical safety and
you know be the fcc in the usa and the
ce standards in the in the eu so
maybe it is possible maybe it is not
um on this final slide now um there's a
there's a kind of big question around
well does this regulation stifle
innovation is it too much for small
companies to try out new ideas
because the cost of meeting those
standards and obligations too high
if you can see in the background there
is a picture of somebody i won't say who
they are but
they're a very high profile person in
the uk government
uh who enjoys talking about technology
and
this person said that actually the eu
own
regulation only helps the incumbent
large organizations
cement their position and it prevents
and keeps out smaller
businesses and kind of innovation but
actually
the same thing was said about the gdpr
that it would stifle innovation that was
too costly
but now across you know all those
different
groups generally is considered a success
generally i mean there's annoying things
about it
and what it has done is it hasn't
stifled innovation what it has done is
set out a clear picture of
what good business models look like as
well as saying
these business models are not welcome
and this is the ambition for the
ai proposals as well um and just an
indication that they are thinking about
um uh innovation um yeah the
the proposals talk about regulatory
sandboxes so the
the willingness to learn by saying okay
we'll pick a few companies
and allow them to experiment to see you
know does the current uh regulation
uh is it good enough can it be improved
are we stopping good uses of
of data and algorithms um i'll stop
there because i know we only had a few
minutes to talk
but i hope that's given you a kind of an
overview of
where we've come from and where we're
going and just an overall
shape of the regulations and if you're
very keen on um
if you if you are scared by them or if
you think they're wrong you know they're
there it's currently
um you know there's a chance to contact
and your representatives and encourage
change um thank you for listening
if you want to talk to me i'm i'm at
digital dynamics you can find me on the
internet
fantastic so thank you very much
um i i didn't say it in the beginning
um but the uh to the to the audience you
you there is a q a
function that you can use to ask
questions and or you can also
post them in the chat function if you
want to
um maybe uh i'll
i'll buy everyone in the audience some
time to to
think of a question or formulate that
question by asking one quick question
myself
terry i i was i was wondering
do these regulations also define what
exactly an
ai algorithm is i mean
if i'm let's say a startup and i use
k-means clustering or something like
that to segment my
you know visitors to my website somehow
yeah
is that already an ai algorithm an
application of ai
yeah so the the answer is they they do
attempt to define um what kinds of
algorithms are covered by the by the
proposals
and this is problematic because you can
always find
an algorithm which is on the edge or
fuzzy or just outside
and this is why many people are warning
against
overly prescriptive descriptions um
the the the lawmakers at the moment are
saying that they will
keep updating the proposals but you
can't do that
in an agile way you can't do that every
six months so there's some risks there
but but actually overall if we take a
step back
i would say that from a position of no
regulation
to a position where you're regulating 80
percent of algorithms that really should
be
implemented regulated because they have
the risk to people
that is better than allowing perfection
to be the enemy of you know getting it
80 right
so yes there are challenges um and you
will always find um
you know is k means ai or not
is a linear regression here you're not
you know um
um is everything is everything in ai
linear regression you know
so so so you know that's a mathematical
discussion
um but i think overall the the the
it i think that would be more good than
that bad
and we just want to make sure that um
the approach isn't discredited by too
many people
um saying actually this this doesn't fit
and now the regulation looks silly
i think the that's the reputation risk
is the biggest there
sure sure that makes sense thank you
very much
thank you so much just stay right to the
end so if anyone has any questions
i'll like happy to talk at the end as
well yeah sure
so i got one as well if uh
yes of course yeah okay so i was
hearing to the talk and i was thinking
wouldn't be or wouldn't make more sense
to
uh rather than certify and
qualify the algorithms that are created
to certify and qualify the people who
create
and in kind of some way
make them accountable for the decisions
for the models and algorithms that they
deploy
to the population rather than on the
on the machines and the techniques
yeah i think that's a very good um point
um so if we look at established
industries because
people think that ai is very new and but
often we can learn from other sectors
so if we look at information security or
even
medicine or even engineering civil
engineering building engineering
you do both you you create a class of
people who
you certify as having sufficient
learning
knowledge experience expertise
so you can trust them either to do the
assessments or to
you know build things and then when
things are
i carry enough risk that they can hurt
people
either physically or in terms of life
chances you want to certify the systems
so you certify buildings as being safe
you certify medical equipment
even though the people who built them
already certified
in information security you have
qualified professionals
of various standards and they very they
wear various hats and badges
but the systems they design and build
also in various sectors have to be
uh accredited or short or certified um
so you we we end up doing both um and i
think that's the same
that will happen here so yes there is a
focus unfortunately on the
in the in the proposed regulations on
certifying systems
you raise a good point we should also
think about certifying individuals
personally i think in the development
of this profession we're still too early
you know we are where we were 20 30
years ago with information security
the people who were good at it but there
wasn't yet enough consensus around
what does it mean um for somebody to be
given a certification
but we will get there overall
the more fundamental point um that the
regulation
the upholds is that
even if systems are certified the
ultimate accountability
and responsibility lies with individuals
so it's very firm on not separating
systems from the people who build them
run them and are accountable for them
so you can't blame the system
like the government recently did last
summer with you know the a the mutant ai
in the immutant algorithm that that
created crazy a-level results for
students
that was a an intention perhaps
to distance create some distance between
the algorithm and those who should have
been responsible for its quality
and his performance so i'm really
pleased that the
proposed regulations do refirm
restate that it's individuals who are
responsible
that's a really really good question
thank you yeah i mean and your answer
makes a lot of sense i was just thinking
as a follow-up question do you know
or do you have any data points on the
existing industries
i can think of like a bank investment
is a is an industry that's certified
people i think to
to take the decision and give them kind
of a counseling or whatnot
but do you know in this established
industries
what came first certifying the systems
or certifying the people
um i don't know um about those um that's
a really good question and i should
for my own learning look it up um did um
did did the certification of buildings
confessed or did
the certifying builders come first um
that's a really good question yeah i i
will go away and look that up i think
it's
very very interesting yeah oh thank you
very much for the talk
yeah thank you great question
yes um i think in the interest of
of time i think we should conclude
uh here and if anyone has a has a
follow-up question you know please do
reach out to tariq
using that chat um
right i
think uh i think in in the i think in
the agenda i put
i wrote sort of like uh that we would
have a short interval
but um i i would if
there are no objections i would suggest
the um
you know we move straight to the next
talk
if that's okay nishat are you there
yep i'm here okay fantastic
great um so i i i must
apologize uh here i i know you sent me
a brief biography and i wanted to use
that to introduce you before your talk
but i i unfortunately i put i downloaded
the email to
my to another laptop and and now i can't
reach it
very sorry about that would you mind uh
just
helping me by by saying a few words
about what you do before your before
your talk
that would be a great help sure
okay and the stage is yours
thank you i will share my screen and um
[Music]
talk about myself once i've done that
are you able to see my slide
yes looks great brilliant um
yes thank you uh yeah so my name is
nishad
by way of introduction i work at
cmr surgical
in a team of kind of data scientists and
engineers
i mainly do data engineering um
previously um i was at the whittle lab
at the university of cambridge um doing
some aeronautics research
um and the
the work that i did i'm talking today
about
some of the work that i did while i was
at the lab
um so i'm going to talk for maybe about
10 minutes at most um it's going to
start off with
a very short introduction to nurbs
curves
and then i'll talk about how i use them
to generate
two-dimensional aerofoils for my
research
so for the introduction a kind of you
know
the level of detail is you know the sort
of thing that you can find
uh if you you know google for nurbs and
basis lines on
on the internet um and then the air of
oil stuff is
you know things that i learned at the
whittle lab
so nurbs is the acronym for
non-uniform rational basis splines
so let's let's take that one at a time
so a spline is a piecewise polynomial
this this image is off of wikipedia um
three three curves joined together um so
that that's where that kind of
that's what it means to to have a spline
um
basis functions are a bit of mathematics
that i
don't fully understand but they're kind
of linearly combined
to form these spline functions
and then they're kind of defined by
control points and knots
um so in the in the image that these
black dots are control points
um and the knots kind of
determine how how the basis functions
relate to
these control points to give give you
this curve more on that in a sec
uh and then the last thing i'll mention
here is that um
the spline function the b spline
function uh has an argument
uh and the argument is a sort of
distance along the curve uh so you might
say you know t
equals zero reverse to maybe this is the
start and then as t increases you go
along
uh and then t equals one you'd probably
uh you know finish off
uh there and then the knots are defined
as
different values of t
so control points have the largest
influence on the curve shape
but knots determine how much of a curve
is affected by a single control point
um so for example here you can see
[Music]
you know just moving that one control
point um
changes the curve kind of locally but
doesn't really affect the curve
all the way out here
and for most kind of b-spline use cases
a uniform
kind of selection of knots is perfectly
fine
so with non-uniform knots uh
you can give one control point more
influence
on the curve um but usually
when you talk about non-uniformity it's
more extreme than that
so you can have duplicate knots uh to
make a curve
less smooth so for example uh a cubic
spline will become quadratic at the
you know if if there's a duplicate knot
at that point
it will switch from being to quadratic
and then if you add enough duplicate
points you can you can add a kind of
sharp corner
or even a discontinuity to your code
and then the last letter in the acronym
that i'll explain is r which stands for
rational
um so it's not actually possible
to represent um circles and ellipses
exactly using
piecewise polynomials but what you can
do is you can project
a higher dimensional polynomial curve to
obtain
an exact representation of you know
conic sections so you know for example
you can
project a 3d curve into two dimensions
uh to get an exact circle um
now in nurbs books and
libraries um this extra dimension is
usually called the weight
and the weight is defined on control
points so you can think of
you know a control point with more
weight will pull the curve towards it
and then this this just shows kind of
different conic sections so you have
circles ellipses
um parabolas hyperbola hyperbolas
okay so now you know a little bit a
little bit about nurbs um there are
special types of
b-spline that can have varying levels of
smoothness and they can exactly
represent conic sections
such as circles and ellipses and kind of
just uh just a little bit of history um
the the origins of these drafts people
apparently used to have kind of bendy
pieces of wood
um that were kind of held in position by
lead weights so
you know those are the kind of
algorithmic representation of a very
similar thing where you have control
points actually those kind of weights
which i thought um so yeah next i'm
going to add what airfoils
there are many ways of specifying
aerofoil cross-sections
the method that i used for my research
was to combine a
camber curve with a thickness curve
and for those of you that don't know
what camber is it's kind of useful to
think of it
backwards so if you start with the kind
of two-dimensional airfoil
the camber line is calculated as the set
of points that's kind of
halfway between the upper and lower
curves
and then the you know the thickness is
kind of just added on
kind of uh perpendicularly to all of
these
you know it's laid on top of the the
camber curve
at the top and the bottom
so using this method um doesn't
necessarily tell you
how the upper and lower surfaces will be
joined
the leading edge or at the trailing edge
of the airport
and my in in my work i used um
nerves to generate multiple kind of
joining curves
and also to switch between parabolic and
circular shapes
a quick aside with aerofoils you usually
have to design them to be
curvature continuous to get the best
performance and to clarify what i mean
is on the right we've got continuous
curvature
all the way around here because it's a
circle and then a discontinuity
where the curvature jumps to infinity
and then this is a
kind of discontinuity in gradient so a
discontinuity in curvature there and
just continue to integrate into there
and then on the left for comparison um
you can just
you know just move some control points
around to give a smoother you know
curvature continuous
shape so so it should look smoother
eyeballs can usually pick up you know
big changes in curvature so you might
notice like
something here but you know this this
bit looks uh looks quite smooth
uh anyway so putting this putting all of
this together um
the algorithm that i used to join uh was
simply to kind of append
uh the three curves together
add a knot on either side of the join
and then remove all the duplicate knots
um so in the plot i've got
you know these three kind of
component curves with their control
points shown
and then the kind of joined curve on the
on the right
which hopefully looks looks quite smooth
you know in theory it's curvature
continuous
i can also show in the next two slides
um the kind of very small changes in
control points that take place as part
of the stream so
you know this is the kind of uh
the three codes before you join and then
after join
you know there's a very small change
but the kind of yeah the circular aspect
is preserved and
you know most of this curve and uh you
know
the upper surface of the lower surface
sorry
curve are are still preserved
um and then changing the weight of just
that one control point uh makes the
curve parabolic instead of circular
so again i'm going to flick between two
slides so this is this is circular
and then if i change the weight of that
point to one
it becomes parabolic and then
looking at the join as well it's a very
localized
change the rest of the curve isn't
affected and the joint is still kind of
uh curvature continuous
um and that's pretty much it so just to
finish off um this is a
you know pi later talk so i um i should
mention the python
i'm aware of only two points in
libraries for working with nurbs um so i
used
high nurbs for my research and then uh
geomdl
um to make the this presentation um i
don't think my nerves is
actively maintained anymore so if you're
thinking of using those you're probably
better off using
the second of the two um
and yeah that's pretty much it um that
there might well be kind of better ways
of joining
um curves to get nodes curves together
so
you know if anyone in the audience has
experience with um
you know using using these curves in you
know
cad or cam then please let me know
thank you um i guess i can take
questions at this point
yes please um
again sorry i'm trying to see how to
are there any questions i i think i'm
going to
give everybody time to think good
question to ask
something myself um
maybe it's so i i have to say um
i have to actually make it two questions
we'll see
um one is probably
very simple but i i have to i i have to
sort of like
uh stand up and say very clearly i'm not
100 sure
how an aerofoil is defined i i get it's
it's sort of like it had sort of the
shape of
a of a of a ring in an airplane is
is it just is it just that or does it
have a more general meaning
um
i'm not sure i
understand what you mean um
[Music]
so you know you you could say that
something something like this you know
with with uh with the upper and lower
surfaces uh
joined is a 2d air foil
yes and then if you you know actually
wanted to to put it on
on a plane um you'd have to kind of make
that into a
into an actual volume so you might have
um
the same shape just kind of extruded
yeah
to make make your airfoil um and then
there's kind of 3d design
where where you might kind of uh you
know not just extruded but also kind of
slightly shrink it as it get
you know slightly taper it as you get
away from the kind of main fuselage
you might sweep it backwards for um
good um yeah good aerodynamic kind of
practice
but yeah this is just considering um
the kind of just just the 2d section yes
yes
yes yes absolutely uh you
you you have you have exactly answered
my questions thank you very much
i see there is a question here
um from from the audience
um um do
i'm just going to read it out quickly do
nurbs and splines have mathematical
properties
making them useful in data fitting my
limited understanding suggests they are
good for meeting edge and boundary
conditions
again i might need to ask for a
clarification on the question but yeah
um splines uh are quite often um used
to kind of you know fit a curve to a
bunch of data points um there's you know
um our functions built into numpy for
example
for for getting a b-spline um if you've
got a if you've got a set of data points
um some of these nurbs libraries
do have um kind of built-in functions
for
fitting you know a spline to your data
um but i guess
most of the time you know just regular
beast blinds are good enough so
maybe that's why people don't tend to
have algorithms for
fitting nerves but yeah the algorithms
do exist
[Music]
does that kind of answer your question
i'm i don't see
and see a response so i guess that this
answered
the question yes thank you
[Laughter]
okay
okay um i i gather
your work um was
related in sort of like finding
good uh shapes
or 2d shapes for such an aerofoil except
is that right
and how do you how do you then
i mean how do you then evaluate the the
the quality of that design or the shape
that you found
well what's your so yeah
there's different levels of um kind of
evaluation um probably in the first
instance you can do a 2d
simulation um so you know
you're just just looking at the kind of
flow around
this 2d shape
[Music]
the next step up would be doing a 3d
simulation you might have kind of
time accurate simulations um
sort of that's the kind of simulation um
side of things
and then obviously you can just uh print
off
you know in a 3d printer this this
aerofoil you can you know just just
extrude it
um and kind of test it in the wind
tunnel
um so yeah that's kind of different
levels of
uh evaluation if that kind of makes
sense um
but usually you you get a you get a
reasonably good
idea of how well the shape is going to
do just based on your 2d and 3d
simulations
and then if it's kind of very specific
you know fine tuning that you need to do
um that's when you might look at you
know unsteadily the you know time
accurate simulations
or looking at wind tunnel wind tunnel
data
cool yeah yeah that sounds very
interesting
another question yes with the airfoil
example many different splines will fit
to join the bottom and top curves what
is optimized in choosing the best line
um
i don't know i i haven't done a kind of
optimization exercise
um i just needed something that would
work
so you know you kind of going down the
joining splines
um method is is is one approach that i
was saying of
specifying airfoil cross-sections uh
another way that you can
um specify uh aerofoils is to start with
this kind of
camber distribution um
and the way that you kind of generate
your upper and lower surfaces
uh is that you kind of roll a circle
um around the the kind of camber line um
so that the radius of the circle will
start off here
um with this kind of thickness but then
by the time it gets here the circle will
have grown to
that thickness and so if you do that
then you get
you know a full layer of oil without
needing to join anything
or you can have kind of um
[Music]
kind of fully algorithmically specified
aerofoil so um the naca which is the
kind of
precursor to nasa um has
for example uh a four series of
aerofoils
um so so you can specify your whole
error for 2d airfoil
just using four digits and it's and it's
things like
where is the the location of uh maximum
camber
and what's the the maximum thickness of
the aerocoil
and you can you know using just those
four digits and you know
the the kind of aerofoil generation
formula generator a whole family of
aerofoils
without even you know getting into
splines
[Music]
yeah i i guess i used nurbs because i
wanted to be able to make
that circular leading edge but also
look at parabolic um
but you know if you were only looking at
parabolic then you could probably get
away with just a
just a regular uniform
basis line
interesting thank you very much
thank you yeah well i'll stop sharing i
guess
i don't think there's any more questions
i
i don't see any more questions uh
i don't hear anything else
um okay um again thanks a lot to both
speakers nishat and tariq um was
both very interesting talks and um
um what i think i also forgot to say at
the beginning was that
um v the pi data cambridge
uh meetup we're going to have a a break
for of of virtual meetups for for a
little bit
just with just because we've been we've
been uh
going for a while so the pandemic and i
said we i thought we
deserve a bit of a break but we are
looking to
um resume with in-person meetups in due
course and
if you're interested in presenting or if
you have ideas for for
um things that you want to hear about
please do reach out and
uh you know we would be very happy to
talk um
okay um that's that's it for for today
and thanks a lot for everyone who died
in
to all the speakers and uh hope to see
you all soon again
okay bye-bye very much thanks
evening bye have a good evening
you